Welcome back to
Ukraine, marking the anniversary
of the liberation of bootcamp,
the town near key
that the Ukrainian
president calls
a symbol of Russian atrocities.
Vladimir Zelenskiy
says Ukraine will never forgive
those responsible.
Moscow's
forces occupied that town for 33 days
And mass graves were found after
it was recaptured
when the occupying troops left bodies
in the streets as they escaped.
They are accused of executions, of rape
and of torture.
Russia denies those accusations.
Ukraine's resilience is on full display
in a frontline
town in the eastern part of the
country today.
Drinking water
that has become hard to get.
But as Ben Wedeman reports, residents
carrying on
with some help from the outside
Without water, there is no life.
And the clean water
pouring into these plastic jugs
is a vital lifeline for people
in the battered eastern Ukrainian
town of Siversk
just six miles from Russian lines.
Retired building contractor Andrei
Anderson from Oregon
is an unlikely carrier of water.
It was just a calling
that I couldn't refuse to do.
I can't sit at home and allow
allow this to happen
without helping the people who need help.
He's part of a volunteer group
called Aqueducts.
They're routine, simple but essential.
We turn up,
they turn up with our little jugs
and we fill up their jugs
or that buckets or their cow pails,
and they get away happy.
And we have our tank.
We drive home,
and then we come back in the afternoon
and we do the same thing
and we repeat on every day.
The few remaining in severe
tell the usual story
dogged attachment to their land
and no other options.
How can I leave?
Ask Tanya.
My son is buried here
and where would I go
with my small pension?
Andre's colleague,
Silvia Pervis from Austria,
was a tour guide.
Why are you doing this?
To help.
Just the right thing to do.
73 year
old Nikola appreciates the water,
but thirsts for quiet.
No dialog I'm fed up with his shelling.
Nobody needs it, he says.
What passes for daily
life ended long ago.
The center of survivors is a wasteland.
The early spring
snow softens
but can't hide the jagged edges.
Voter
Andre shouts out
Water, vodka, in Ukrainian.
Soon, residents
emerge from their basements,
their bomb shelters.
Basic humanitarian services
like this are critical.
There hasn't been any running water
or electricity
since the beginning of the war.
With no end to this war in sight,
they're resigned to a fate bleak.
Don't worry, it's fine, says Valentina.
We put up with everything.
What can we do? It's totally true.
Yet 70 year old Nina despairs at
what has become of her town hall.
What do we feel?
She asks.
Pain. Pain.
When you see something destroyed,
you tear up.
We cry. We cry.
And we like you.
Bottles now fall.
They return through streets,
cold, muddy
and ravaged to their shelters.
Ben Wedeman, CNN, severe Eastern Ukraine.
Turkey has approved Finland's
bid to join NATO.
After months of delays,
the Turkish parliament
voted unanimously
in favor of Finland's
membership on Thursday.
Clearing
what is the last hurdle for Helsinki.
Well, the vote fulfills a promise
from Turkey's
president
to not oppose Finland's
entry into the alliance.
Now, Turkey was the last of NATO's
30 members
to ratify Finland's membership.
Sweden, of course,
has also applied to join.
But Turkey and Hungary
remain opposed by Sweden.
And Finland
ended decades of neutrality
after Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
Well, Finland's
president thanked every NATO member
for their trust and support
and promised Finland
will be a strong and capable
ally committed to the security
of the alliance.
NATO's secretary general welcoming
the development
and tweeting, quote,
This will make the whole NATO's family
stronger and safer.